hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the quarterfinals of
the fidei 2019 World Cup it's a team
over Java versus Jeffrey's young this is
their second game of the match the
classical one first game ended in a draw
where Sean had the white pieces so it
will be very interesting how he will
fare with the black pieces against her
job off
we do have a nice photo of the matchup
not from this round it's from the
previous round but you know we use what
we have photo courtesy of Kirin where
kuliev official photographer of the 2019
fede World Cup so there you have it just
you know to get in the mood for the game
now let's check it out with the white
pieces our job of opens with d4 and
Knight to f6 with c4 and now we don't go
into something that will go into the
Queens gambit declined but rather g6 we
have Knight to c3 and now d5 the groom
full defense is on the board with CCAP
verse Knight captures and E for we go
into the main line of the groom felled
Knight captures and c3b captures and the
Bishop to g7 Bishop to c4 the main line
well the most popular line here but
Bishop to b5 buyer job of a somewhat
rarer line we have c6 blocking check and
now Bishop back to a4 with castles and
then out Knight to e2 Nakamura also
enjoys playing this Bishop to b5 line
with E 5 by black and now the white king
is still in the center of course black
wouldn't mind the busting open the
center and the problem with for example
something like d5 II d5 is met with
Queen to h4 just going after the e4 pawn
and if you defend it for example 93 then
the other then the rook assumes the D
file and now white will have some
problems so after E 5 a job of just
castles
and now Knight to d7 continuing
development with Bishop to e3 Queen to
e7 and now back to C to weave nice to b6
and now there is one game they reach
this position of a stimulant reverses
Valentin Sorokin in 2006 were Queen to
c1 was played preparing f4 but here a
job of says preparing is for weaklings
I'm just gonna push
for right away and it is as of move 13
would afford that we have a completely
new game so young captures with eke
after son before and now Bishop capture
Sundy for offering a trade of dark
square Bishop cyou mm-hmm well now most
of the times you want to do this as
blacks dragon is his strongest piece so
you do want to trade it rook to b8 it
seems like white will have some problems
here as the bishop is on the same file
is the Queen and if c5 comes it seems
like you're gonna lose a piece here but
her job of continues with the attack he
plays f5 and what does this mean it c5
just winning the piece well not really
if you play C 510 at a job of head f6 in
mind with an attack on the Queen and the
bishop now after we move the Queen you
can continue ePHI further harassing the
Queen Queen c7 and now F captures in g7
C capture son d4 and now as DF file is
opened up for the white rook Bishop to
b3 going after the f7 pawn bishop piece
is defending and now you just recapture
see capture sandy for and the White has
an incredible position here so after f5
of course Geoffrey did not go for c5 he
played the character Sundy for width
Trek with C capture son d4 and now c5
going after the center Queen to d2
preparing something like f6 maybe Queen
to h6 it's still not anything serious as
the Queen always has the retreat square
of a f8 and you will be able to counter
White Queen on it on h6 but now she um
goes after the White Queen with tonight
the C for attacking the Queen Queen to
d3 getting out of the way and now
tonight's the ePHI going after the Queen
yet again and here Queen to a3 now
saying that okay your knight is under
attack and you cannot capture here since
your queen would be hanging on e7 so
tonight back to C for attacking the
Queen and now here she says okay you can
grab my c5 phone if you want but it's
not a good move for example Queen
captures Queen captures pawn captures
and now you get night to e3 and the
White has to give up a rook because if
you try to defend both the rook and the
bishop then you get a rogue d2 and then
now you either lose the piece here or
you lose the piece here there's no way
no way to defend both so
a job of decides okay we're not
capturing here let's just retreat Quinn
back to c3 now and here we have b5 as
there are no more scores where you can
attack the Queen so you just defend the
night with f6 attacking the Queen and
now Queen to d6 it's always important to
keep an eye on that ff8 square for now
the night covers III and d2 so you
cannot go over to h6 right away but you
know and there you can never be too
careful
and now d5 not allowing this capture to
happen and it's it's somewhat too weird
pawn structure in the center but if you
can get rook 81 and maybe push this pawn
to e5 somehow then the central pawn
structure would be very nice we've
looked young and now Bishop to d3 hoping
to capture the night here and here
Knight b6 is one way to do it for
example you give up the b5 point and in
exchange black grabs the e4 pawn
reducing White's Center somewhat but she
um decided to go for night the e3 it's a
similar button not quite here a Java
played Bishop captures on b5 with rook
captures on e4 now the night is defended
and now Knights to g3 and here's where
the party really starts so how do you
how do you do this do you capture the
rook and give up your own rook it's a
very interesting line but the problem is
if you capture on f1 yes you keep an eye
on the h2 pawn so now if white captures
here you can capture on h2 with the
Queen but then the problem is why - just
recaptures and you're down a piece and
you don't have good compensation for
your pieces are undeveloped and you have
no way of continuing the attack Queen h1
does it doesn't really do anything as
the white queen guards the rook on a1 so
after night the g3 we don't have Knight
captures on f1 but rather Knight to g4
an excellent attacking move now of
course if our job of captures the rook
its Queen captures on h2 with checkmate
so after knife the g4 we have rook a to
c1 going after the c5 pawn and here
Geoffrey just pushes it c4 trying to buy
some time for example if the bishop
captures then he can play H 5 H 4 and so
on maybe dislodge this night and
continue the attack but our job is not
interested he plays h3 he
says okay you move the night I just
capture your rook on e4
so everything is good Shion goes
Bishop to b7 now with the idea of
creating some threats here he gives up
the knight on g4 but it's it's actually
a very nice sacrifice that a job of
accepts it with pawn captures on g4 and
now rook captures on g4 with a double
attack on the night and things get
really complicated here another move
other than rook captures and G for Queen
to c5 check was possible as it goes
after the bishop on b5 right away if
you're yeah if you're eager to you know
win your piece back right away for
example rook f2
now you go Ruka for go after the rook
and only after your trade ropes let's
say rook f1 real captures rook captures
then you recapture on b5 but assume is
not in a hurry to win here when his
sacrifice piece he just plays the rook
captures on g4 as he's such a such a
great attacker and now again what do you
play here how do you how do you defend
the night it's it's not simple if you
play 92 just get the knight out of the
way to negate Queen captures on d5 now
you have all these threats on g2 it will
be impossible to defend
so black would be of course winning here
and on the other hand if you try to
defend it it is possible to go rook to
f3 just defend it and give up the d5
pawn your rook is under attack you move
the rook then comes Queen e3 with an
attack on the bishop pressuring the rook
so now a rope capture series and the
rook captures Knight is a threat as the
rock is spin so here white and not the
greatest continuation for white so here
our Java finds the best idea Bishop to
c6 give up the g3 night but for some
excellent excellent play with rook
captures and g3 now comes Queen captures
on c4 and of course she is not
interested in giving the job of this
very strong past C pawn so he plays a
very tricky move he doesn't go for rook
to see a truck the c8 is one way to do
it but as both of them are real at one
time it's you know every every second is
it's valuable he plays Bishop to e6 and
Bishop to e6 just shows you how creative
she young is it's it's really just a
crazy you know what sorcery is this move
and the thing is if you capture the
the shop it's it's very hard to spot
blacks idea for example if the bishop is
captured then she owns idea is rook to
h3 the point is if you capture the rook
then of course it's it's a draw by
perpetual check linking h1 Queen
captures King goes here Queen captures
and so on on the other hand after this
rook takes to remove if you don't
capture it it's hard to find a good
continuation because Queen to h2 is
coming so white is better here but it
when both of them are very long time
it's impossible to allow such a
continuation for black you would have to
find Queen to c4 and it's it's a very
hard move to find you have to allow all
of these chicks Queen h2 check can give
to Queen g3 check now if you go back
it's just a draw by repetition so you
have to go further above the board you
cannot go rotate check as the bishop
covers d8 square but you can go rook h2
now threaten to capture here but then
white plays d6 and now you see that the
best regards the gg to pawn so it's not
incredibly difficult to find but with
little time on the clock you do not want
to risk this so after Bishop days 6 at a
job of instead goes Queen to f4 so you
cannot capture the rook now because
Queen captures Queen Raja wants to trade
Queens
we've looked the d8 now again the eeoa
does not have a problem trade trading
Queens but first we have Roxy t1 now
threatening some very nasty ideas Quint
h6 is not a problem our job of could
force the Queen trade here Queen to f8
just goes back after scatters the rook
everyone getting the rock out of the way
but he prefers rooks e2 e1 now the thing
is of course if you if you play
something like Queen captures here it's
not gonna be all that weight and
especially if you play Bishop captures
on f1 that could be very bad because
Queen captures and d6 rook captures and
now the real idea behind rook to e1 is
just the rook to e8 mate
so after rook C to e 1 with Queen to c5
with check and rook to f2 blocking and
the now rook the c3 your Rukh is still
hanging here so you have to bring it
back
ding was having an interview he was also
commentating
this game because his game would Alex
not agree she finished before this game
and he showed a very funny line so I'm
just gonna show it
what happens if Queen to c3 just
defending the rogue this way and
attacking the rook here abandoning your
well defense of the f8 square and he now
showed if Queen to h6 then you get Queen
captures anyone with check and if King
to h2 now it seems like you're getting
checkmated but you're actually not
because of rook to h3 check and now you
either have to bring the Queen back and
then black just grabs the pawn here you
could do grab with the rook with the
King then you get just Quint h1 check in
g3 and you lose the Queen on h6 or after
Luke to h3 you could capture with the
Jeep on but then you get Queen captures
an f2 with checking each one and now
Queen captures this point so there is no
mate and now you are just up a whole
rook so really really very nice of dingo
for showing us this funny line after
winning his game against Ganesha
but okay in the game rope the c3 by
Shion and the now comes a move that
that's actually a very nice move so we
already said that Queen to h6 followed
by Queen to g7 mate is what this game is
all about this is what a jobber went for
when he played f5 and f6
but today the constant problem is that
she owns Queen is covering the f8 square
so the g7 square will always be
protected so here we have looked east 7
just Quinte h6 again also possible you
could go for this and go for the Queen's
raid but a Java finds rook to e7 now the
Queen can no longer go to f8 the block
mate
and there is only one good continuation
that that saves the game for for Sheung
so pause the video here and try to find
this defensive idea maybe maybe we can
you know do this a bit more often
pausing the video to find offensive
ideas as well well I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on the
congratulations on defending such a you
know difficult position to defend and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
the only good move is rook to c2 now you
have this very nice pin you just attack
the pink piece now of course quintic
Queen to h6 is nothing because you just
get made at Queen captures rockin h1
Queen captures and g2 is made so look
the c2 really creates problems for white
you will not be able to continue with
your attack you will have to go back for
example Queenie three or four Queen
trade and then the game continues but
she did not find rook to c2 she only
played rook the c1 check we have kinked
h2 and now look back to c3 probably with
the idea that after Queen to h6 he can
deliver some checks and then go look the
c1 maybe continue checking the white
king the problem is it doesn't work so
here I'm not gonna even ask you to pause
the video as we already discussed that
the main theme of the game is going to
h6 so here in this position our job of
just played Queen to h6 and it was in
this position unmoved 36 that jefra she
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to do here
he saw that after this check for example
you couldn't deliver a queen to d6 check
but now the problem is the King will not
go back allowing rook to c1 or something
but just rook to f4 you block check and
next move its Queen to g7 checkmate
and there are no more tricks there are
no more checks there there is nothing
black can do this to even hope you know
to save this game so definitely a a very
interesting game a tough game really a
wonderful attacking game by both of them
jefra really showed you know some really
really interesting and tricky lines
especially that bishop the a6 move
definitely my favorite move of the game
but it was not enough for a job of takes
him down and with this game shown is
eliminated from the Vita World Cup 2019
we're team our job of advances so a job
of and the dink are the two
semi-finalists now and we will have to
wait and see what what did the other
players will do tomorrow in the in the
rapid section so once again that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Pablo Naga abdul-jabbar
and Raul Wasserman for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it I would
just like to mention that Abdallah
Jabara created a sort of a noggin
mothers chess club on chess calm I will
put a link to it in the description
below it will be the first thing you
will see so if you want to join his club
if you play on chess calm feel free to
join his chess club and you know I have
some fun and enjoy some tournaments but
yeah as usual you can check two of my
previous videos see our think'll for
watching and I will see you soon
covering more of the games of defeated
World Cup 2019 and checking up on your
wonderful suggestions so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day